-Our first guest tonight
is the Vice President of
the United States.
Please welcome back to the show
Vice President Kamala Harris,
everyone.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Welcome back.
-It's good to be back.
It's good to be back.
-It's very exciting to have you,
especially to have you here
as the Vice President.
We've had you on the show
before as a senator.
And I have noticed
the security protocols
have changed a great deal.
[ Laughter ]
I don't know
if we're overprotecting
our vice presidents or
under-protecting our senators.
[ Laughter ]
I can't imagine how much
that part of it
has changed your life.
How have the security protocols
just infringed on being
a normal human being?
-Well, okay, one example would
be my husband, Doug and I,
the first Second Gentleman of
the United States.
-Very exciting.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I do want to focus -- I feel
like we're not focusing enough
on what white men have
accomplished with your rise.
[ Laughter ]
-I know.
It's exactly -- We have jokes
about that too.
But, you know, we love
to take walks,
and these days the walks
are quite different.
So, I love "The Godfather."
So, okay, do you know that --
Do you know "The Godfather"?
-Yeah, this is not where I
thought your nice walk --
[ Laughter ]
-No, I'm gonna tell you.
So, you know that scene
when Michael is in Italy,
he had to leave.
-Yes.
-Okay, and then he's courting
that woman.
And they decide to take a walk
through the village.
And so the shot is just the two
of them taking this lovely walk,
and then it pans out and the
whole village is with them?
-Yes.
-That's what our walks are like.
[ Laughter ]
-A little bit --
a little bit less romantic.
-It's a little different.
It's a little different. Yeah.
-So, we mentioned obviously
already in the show, this sort
of historic act about marijuana,
and certainly at
the federal level.
The question, I guess is, you
know, it's actually not that
many people are affected by it,
but it's such a big step in
the right direction.
What happens next, other than
just pressuring governors to do
the same on the state level?
Is there -- Do you see
legislation in the future?
-Well, you know, we've tried
over the years, but I -- let me
just start with saying this.
I strongly believe, and
the majority of Americans agree,
nobody should have to go to jail
for smoking weed, right?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Right? And so we start with
that, and then we are,
to your point, urging -- and the
President has been very clear --
we're urging governors
and states to take our lead
and to pardon people who have
been criminalized
for possession of marijuana.
And ultimately, though, as with
so many issues, if Congress
acts, then there is a uniform
approach to this
and so many other issues,
but Congress needs to act.
We're 29 days away
from the midterms.
Ask who you're voting for
where they stand on this,
and I encourage you
to vote accordingly.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-As an administration, you have
accomplished a great deal
despite only having
a 50/50 Senate.
-Yeah.
-You know, you mentioned 29 days
out from the midterms.
What is different if you win
two more Senate seats?
What is the message as far as
what will change for Americans'
lives if you have that sort of
majority in the Senate
that isn't weighing on
maybe two Democratic senators
who aren't always as in-line
with the party?
-There's so much, Seth,
that changes.
So, 29 days.
The Dobbs decision.
So, the United States
Supreme Court, the highest court
in our land, just took
a constitutional right that had
been recognized
from the people of America,
from the women of America,
right?
And the significance of that is
profound in terms of what it
means for the rights of
individuals and, in particular,
for the right of an individual
to make decisions about
their own body and not have
their government
tell them what to do.
But in addition, what it means
for the next 29 days is,
if we keep our numbers in
the Senate and elect two more
United States Senators, then the
President can sign into law
the Women's Health Protection
Act, which would put
into law the protections
of Roe v. Wade.
So critically important.
29 days to go.
And the reality of it is that,
on the one hand, 29 days.
Everyone has a lot going on,
very busy, and it's gonna take
an effort to make sure
that you vote.
On the other hand, these House
seats, they're two-year terms.
These Senate seats,
six-year terms.
So think about it.
Whether we let it go with
status quo the way it is now
for the next two years or six
years, or in the next 29 days.
Make a plan to vote and actually
vote on this issue.
-I think that --
[ Cheers and applause ]
I think correctly, you know,
a lot of people think about
abortion as an important issue,
but you've also talked about
maternal health, which seems
like that would be the one that
would seem like everyone could
agree on because the health of
a mother, the health of a child,
this -- based on what both sides
of the aisle say, this is
deeply important to them.
And yet it seems as though
we can't even reach a consensus
on that.
Can you just talk about the
importance of maternal health
and steps that we can take
to make life better
for certainly young mothers?
-Yeah, it's a critically
important issue.
And I know you've spoken up
on this over the years.
In our country today,
women are still dying in
connection with childbirth.
And when you look at, then, the
racial disparities, Black women
are three times more likely to
die, Native American women twice
as likely to die,
women in rural America
1.5 times more likely to die.
And a lot of it has to do with,
again, the disparities
in the healthcare system, and
that we are not putting enough
attention and resources
and priority into women's needs,
especially as it relates to
their reproductive health.
And I do want to say this also.
This is an issue
that affects all genders.
If you have a partner, if you
have a sister, if you have
an aunt, a mother,
this affects you.
Not to mention on
the Dobbs decision when
Justice Clarence Thomas said
the quiet part out loud,
which is that when they took the
constitutional right from women
on reproductive choice,
that he said, that in-line,
in terms of what
might come next,
is your right to contraception.
That will affect all genders.
Your right to marry the person
you love, same point.
And so there is so much
on the line with these issues
that affects everyone
and the people you love.
And for that reason, let's take
it seriously and let's,
you know, speak with our vote
and undo what I think is a great
travesty of justice as it
relates to that Dobbs decision.
-I have a lot more to ask you.
-Okay.
-I do hope you'll stick around.
We'll be right back with more
from the Vice President,
everybody.